when we think of surfboards
we usually picture brightly colored
lengths of foam and fiberglass composite
so it comes as a surprise to see a
wooden surfboard but why after all every
kind of waterborne vessel was once made
from trees that's because no matter what
wood floats two planks of poplar are
glued on either side of a strip of oak
using a template a craftsman draws the
shape he wants for the surfboard with a
Japanese pole saw he cuts the shape out
by hand establishing the basic form of
the surfboard a CNC router quickly and
accurately cuts the inner support
framework for the board from poplar
plywood the builder sources wood from
suppliers who use sustainable forestry
practices
using his pole saw the craftsman
carefully freezed the pieces of the
support framework and removes them
before smoothing the edges with a block
sander he then begins fitting the pieces
together to form the framework for the
spine the Builder uses fast drawing
superglue which bonds powerfully and
quickly allowing him to work fast with
the spine complete he can start gluing
and inserting the ribs the finished
frame resembles the skeleton of a large
fish once the support structure has
cured the craftsman places it on the
bottom skin of the surfboard he
positions it carefully and clamped it
securely in place on a purpose-built jig
he then traces the lines of the frame
onto the skin while measuring and
marking a set distance from the end of
each rib
he squeezes a bead of an epoxy based
glue over the network of lines before
lifting the frame into position on the
skin he clamps everything down and
leaves it to cure overnight the sides of
the surfboard which are called the rails
consists of 12 strips of wood glued and
clamped together layer by layer this
process takes several days
when all of the glue is fully cured the
builder lays a bead of polyurethane glue
on the frame and rails he then lowers
the surfboards top skin into position
and secures it with dozens of clamps he
will let the fully assembled board cure
overnight
once it is cured the board is ready for
the final phase of production the
craftsman must shape and smooth the wood
to give the object its final shape
the rails act as cutting guides as he
uses a pole saw to trim off the skin
where it overlaps them
with a small Japanese maid wood plane he
begins to round the top edges of the
board clients with a DIY philosophy can
sign up for workshops at this facility
in which they learn to make their own
surfboard the builder also uses a
special tool called a saw ASP a square
ensures he starts from the same point on
the bottom and top when shaping the nose
and tail the saw ASP
shapes the wood quickly and efficiently
now that the surfboard has its final
shape the craftsman uses a sanding block
with increasingly finer grits of
sandpaper to create a smooth surface he
signs the bottom of the board with a
pencil before burning it into the wood
with a tool called a pyrography pen
a layer of fiberglass and epoxy gives
the wood a tough outer shell customers
can choose to have a thin box with a
removable fin or they can opt for a
permanent wooden fin traditional
material plus an innovative design
results in wooden surfboards that are
built to last